minutemate park in houston for game two
between the miami marlins and the
atlanta brains 22 year old rookie
right-hander ian anderson who made only
six regular season starts all ready for
game two cory dickerson
and a swing and a miss ian anderson
starts his second postseason start
with a strikeout
ball in two strikes from anderson
pitching with one gun is starting to
ball
and he rings up birdie strikeouts in the
first two at-bats for anderson today
runners at first and second two down now
for garrett cooper
first pitch to garrett cooper is sent
out to right field and the opposite
field line drive gets him out of any
further difficulty couple of strikeouts
two left stranded 24 year old right
hander pablo lopez cuny leads things off
oh and two to ronda lacuna
lopez makes quick work of him on the
change up one god marcelo zuna one of
the best fastball hitters in the land
on the ground for anderson
double clutches a couple times still
with plenty of time to get ozuna and a
neat tidy one two three start to the
afternoon for pablo lopez leadoff hitter
this inning matt joyce
off to a good start as he strikes out
matt joyce so change-ups from anderson
look to the hitter fastball like they're
across seam fast at no point until it's
about three feet in front plate you
realize it's a lot slower than this
fastball sierra playing center field in
place of starling marty who was not on
this postseason roster
and a wave and a missed by sierra four
early strikeouts for the rookie
right-hander couple of scoreless innings
have started the afternoon we go to the
bottom of the second two gone now for
dansby swanson
swanson with a drive out to left field
that ball well hit dickerson looking up
and that one is gone
second of this postseason for dansby
swanson and from a guy that doesn't give
up a lot pablo lopez allowed only four
homers
in 57 plus innings of work during the
regular season one-nothing atlanta
wallace against ian anderson in the
third
and a swing and a miss that's five first
time through the order for ian anderson
back to the top of the order now corey
dickerson who struck out in his first
try today
swung on and missed good change out that
had a big tail on it six strikeouts now
brian anderson it's gonna be up to
freddie freeman now with two outs trying
not to strand a lead off double to one
two
and freeman hits it on the ground it's
smothered by birdie to his feet to first
to save a run
a fantastic play by the veteran john
bertie four strikeouts for lopez and now
it's travis darno
oh boy that ball doesn't have a chance
to stick around another homer in the
series for travis darno
we talk about how infrequent it is for
lopez to get touched up with homer's
that's just the first time he's given up
multiple home runs in a game ian
anderson benefits from another brave
solo homer now a two-nothing lead that
he works with as we start the top half
of ending number five seventh pitch of
the at-bat
and roja strikes out on it
following two strikes
is to count to austin reilly who struck
out with a runner at second to start the
third
and he strikes out with a runner at
first tugan
ronda lacuna who has struck out twice
wow that's impressive a big strikeout by
pablo lopez
part of a terrific day for him he sues
aguilar up to the plate one for two of
the single
but he goes down swinging here two away
for anderson
good at bat good battle but it looks
like maybe he got him with a change up
again there it is that three finger
cross seam change up and then right at
the end bottom falls out of it tough to
lay off with some effort again by
anderson he's got a chance to win his
first two post-season starts which will
put him in the history book first
pitching change of the game another
postseason gem by the rookie ian
anderson the bases are loaded now matt
joyce the veteran left-handed battle for
two had a pinch hit single yesterday
and on the first pitch a bouncer up the
line for freeman
and the faces are left loaded in the top
of the sixth
miguel rojas is the first to face the
new pitcher on the mound for the atlanta
braves tyler matsuk and matsuk struck
out all three he faced yesterday
wow he struck out all four he's faced in
the series
rojas didn't agree with that
well a lot of that's off the previews of
that he had a pitch that would have been
ball four that he didn't like this is a
continuation two gone now for chad
wallach
wallock sends the ball into the opposite
corner that could be trouble marcakis is
just shy of the wall to put it away and
retire the side corey dickerson is
aboard to start the eighth will smith
has been outstanding this postseason for
atlanta his next pitch john verde sends
a little flare out to right marcakus has
it drop in
and on two pitches
they get the out at second base wow
stayed with it and threw out dickerson
boy that looked awfully close down there
what great anticipation by nick marquez
you really can't blame dickerson what
could he do
two gone now for brian anderson
and a comebacker for smith
strands a base runner another scoreless
post-season inning for a real bullpen
weapon
ronda lacuna's being held quiet means
he's due one two
oh and they get him for a fourth time
today
got him at the top of the zone that time
it looked like and the marlins are down
to their final out today migo rojas will
try to keep game two alive for the
marlins he's had a frustrating afternoon
back up the middle for albies
and the atlanta braves have become just
the third team in major league history
to spin three shutouts through their
first four postseason games in a year